this is not a particle accelerator a
particle accelerator is not some kind of
evil supervillain torture device a
particle accelerator is used for health
safety discovery and for learning more
about our universe you can't see what it
does but you can feel it the question is
can you survive its effects this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
put your head in a particle accelerator
chances are you've probably already been
exposed to accelerated particles before
so how do you feel from x-rays to
airport security treating wastewater and
killing cancer cells particle
accelerators continue to push the
boundaries on the human potential they
might even hold the secret to
time-travel but with great power comes
great responsibility
and the potential for some pretty
serious accidents in 1978 Russian
scientist Anatoly boo Gorsky was
checking in on the malfunctioning u7t
synchrotron which at the time was the
Soviet Union's largest particle
accelerator of course in those days
checking-in meant putting your head in
there and taking a good hard look for
yourself it's hard to imagine what blue
Gorsky might have been looking for since
you can't physically see accelerated
particles they move nearly as fast as
the speed of light when a safety
mechanism failed sending a radioactive
beam of protons through boo gorski's
head the blinding flash of light isa
brighter than a thousand suns according
to him wasn't actually a burst of
accelerated particles that intense light
was the result of 76 billion electron
volts being rammed through Bogor ski
skull for comparison the standard proton
therapy cancer treatment is no more than
250 million electron volts
firing at a speed 300 times less than
what boo Gorsky got and yet but Gorsky
didn't feel any pain the whole thing
happened in an instant but once it was
over boo gorski's face immediately
started swelling he was rushed to the
hospital where doctors told him he
wouldn't live for much longer
but but Gorsky is still alive today half
of his face is paralyzed he's deaf in
one ear and he suffers from epilepsy but
aside from that he lives a pretty normal
life
so our particle accelerators safe to
touch not quite by today's standards the
u7t synchrotron that shot through boo
gorski's head is actually a very weak
particle accelerator in comparison the
Large Hadron Collider which is the
world's largest and highest energy
particle collider fires at about 200
times more power than the u7t this thing
shoes high-energy beams around a ring
that's 27 kilometers long at a speed
that's equivalent to circling the world
7.5 times per second the purpose of this
is to produce high-energy collisions
that will recreate the same conditions
that followed the Big Bang that created
our universe these collisions might
create new particles which we've never
seen before offering up clues to how you
meet how world and everything else came
into existence do you really want to get
your head in the way of that check your
ego before you hurt yourself and don't
interrupt a particle collider from
uncovering more mysteries for all we
know time travel is possible but can you
imagine how weird it would be to meet a
time traveler well that's a story for
another what if